so it's Thursday meaning we once again
have new unemployment numbers from last
week the numbers are not good 2.4
million more people filed for
unemployment benefits last week and this
in total now is starting to be
staggering just unconscionable numbers
when we total up the job losses from
these 9 or so weeks of coronavirus
unemployment pandemic area era maybe
it's 10 weeks at this point something
like that we are now at 38 point six
million jobs lost if on February 1st
anybody had said my prediction is by
June 1st we will have lost 40 million
jobs which is what it will probably be
after we add another week or two of
numbers I don't think anybody would have
believed it now if you want to find some
kind of like it could be worse type of
thing in the numbers what we can point
to is at least the numbers are declining
each week in terms of new people losing
their jobs in early April each week we
had like more than 6 million people
filed for new unemployment benefits and
then by the end of April early May we
were at 4 million a week 3 million a
week and it sounds crazy but that number
is now down to only 2.4 million more
jobs lost last week so in a sense we're
seeing a decreased rate of people losing
their jobs but once again even with
these diminishing numbers by mid-july we
could be at 50 million 50 million people
having lost their jobs now let's do a
little bit of context because this is
important when we talk about this the
total workforce before the pandemic hit
was estimated at 158 million people so
the country is 331 million people many
of those are children many of those are
retired people so the the the active
working labor force was believed to be a
hundred and fifty-eight million people
so thirty-eight point six million losing
their jobs means that 24.4 call it 25
percent about a quarter of the American
workforce lost jobs during the corona
virus pandemic now we've got to adjust
those numbers a little bit one way a
little bit the other way one reality is
these are probably under estimates
because there are lots of people who
lost jobs but for one reason or another
didn't file unemployment benefits there
may be people who lost a job but they're
independently wealthy or have another
source of income or whatever and they
just decided I'm not gonna go through
the hassle of filing unemployment that's
a small group of people you have a
larger group of people who would file an
unemployment claim except it's a what we
might call a marginal job or a job that
is under the table in which case you
wouldn't be able to file for
unemployment benefits and there is still
some fraction of people who have just
been struggling to get the claim in
because systems have been overloaded
unemployment is run at the state level
50 states 50 different systems some are
mostly phones some are online
combination of the two so in a sense
these numbers are probably too low now
on the other side of this there are
people who lost jobs early on but have
found new jobs so we have a cumulative
total of 38 point six million
unemployment claims in the last nine ten
eleven weeks but some of those people
who lost their job in March for example
have found a new job we don't know
exactly what number that is
but there are businesses that have been
hiring delivery business based
businesses grocery stores places like
Amazon and others have been hiring so
some of the people that lost jobs have
found new jobs now what we can be sure
of is given this bad news the stock
market is gonna do really really well
today and I'm sort of kidding but we've
seen a stock market that's increasingly
divorced from the unemployment news now
as we've talked about before
stock markets often react to how the
news compares to expectations so these
new numbers of about two point forty
four million more people losing their
jobs last week it's more or less in line
with expectation so it may not move the
market very very much so what we may
actually see really shake up the stock
market would be the numbers that we're
going to get about the second quarter in
total so q2
earnings and q2 GDP may be numbers that
really move the stock market potentially
down but maybe not so first we've got
earnings seasons how much did companies
make during the second quarter and
typically we get those numbers for the
second quarter which is April May June
around July 15th we'll start to get
earnings numbers from companies and that
may push the market up it may pull the
market down then we will get GDP numbers
even later on so we'll get initial GDP
estimates for the second quarter on July
30th and then we'll get more accurate
second quarter GDP estimates towards the
end of August so realize that we are not
going to know the full scope of what
happened in this quarter right now
essentially until mid to late August
almost September in practice there are
predictions that we could see a 20% GDP
decline in q2 25% one estimate said 35
percent that's certainly on the very
high end so this is about suffering it's
not about politics but we can't ignore
that historically bad GDP numbers the
worst GDP numbers the country has ever
seen
eight weeks before a presidential
election we will know the full scope of
those those numbers again late August
that may be very very bad for Donald
Trump now for now as states have been
improving on their coronavirus numbers
and putting in place plans to get some
portions of their state economies back
to work my hope is because again for me
this is not political
I'd want things to improve economically
and medically as quickly as is
reasonably possible some portions of
people are going to be getting back to
work hopefully things will tick up a bit
or at least least continue taking down
less and reminder that the most
important takeaway here if we want to
take what's going on and turn it into
action for the long term we've got to
fix the problem now of course over the
long term the lesson here is even
economies that look really good by all
of the traditional indicators are really
really fragile our lack of preparedness
has been exposed here there will be more
pandemics there are going to be more
downturns we can't control that what we
can control is the underlying fragility
of our economic system and it's been
exposed as very very fragile